this next story is one of racism and
sexism on the left and it's sort of
related to the conversation that I had
partially on yesterday's show and
partially on today's show with Jonathan
Hite and to be very clear and these are
not going to come as shocking
clarifications to anybody in the
audience I'm on the left I'm against
racism I'm against sexism so when
something like the women's March gets
filled with anti-semitism tied leaders I
call them out and I get slammed for it
some people will say David that's
friendly fire even if those women's
March leaders are linked to
anti-semitism if they have the right
ideas if they're fighting for the right
things why are you calling attention to
it and I say no no that this is not like
a litmus test type of thing and this is
not at the enemy of my enemy is my
friend or whatever it's just the reality
that we need to keep our noses clean and
we can't look the other way just because
we share some goals with someone when I
criticize Alexandria Acacio Cortes many
people will write in angry and they'll
say okay listen David she's uninformed
but she's new and she's young and she
has the right ideas and you shouldn't
call attention to that fact and I say
well no no she makes those ideas less
likely to be taken seriously when she
presents them in an uninformed way we
all look bad and open ourselves up to
attack from the right for good ideas
when they are presented in this poor way
okay
so that gets me to identity politics
once again identity politics is not a
black and white issue identity is
important identity is people humans are
their identity why would anyone pretend
that identity shouldn't matter when you
meet someone you are immediately on a
subconscious level assessing aspects of
their identity and relating to them as
such this is something humans do so when
people want to discuss issues on the bay
of their identity that's great right we
should celebrate that we should
understand that one's identity gives
them valuable perspective but it can go
too far and when identity becomes a
trump card to silence debate and say
none of your opinions matter because of
my identity and what I have to say
that's a major problem and I've called
it out it's not a gigantic problem on
the left but it exists and I call it out
when I see it all of this leads us to
yesterday when Amy Susskind a notable
feminist activist tweeted the following
quote I will not support white male
candidates in the Democratic primary
unless you slept through the midterms
women were our most successful candidate
biggest dem voters the biggest demo'd
getters in history Obama oh eight
Hillary sixteen white male is not where
our party is at and is our least safe
option in 2020 this is exactly the stuff
that we need to condemn and putting
aside the fact that you would expect
that over time candidates would get more
and more votes because the population
keeps growing like that's a completely
meaningless statement that Obama and
Hillary got record number of votes so
from Democrats
we need to condemn this because of the
idea and I immediately tweeted Amy back
and got a lot of people who agreed with
me and some people who disagreed and
said isn't there something not
progressive about preemptively
dismissing a candidate based on their
race and gender I feel like there's a
word to describe that as a progressive I
won't be jumping on board with that idea
ideas experience ability perspective
issues no she is saying no white men
this is racism and this is sexism so Amy
Siskind started getting crushed by some
on the left for what she said and the
right immediately started holding her up
exactly what they want us to be
portrayed as which is completely
self-destructive for us right so
whatever she meant by this even if we
charitably attribute to her that what
she meant was Oh what I mean is I think
a non someone who's not a white male is
more likely to win okay if that's what
she meant she said it in the worst
possible way and it makes us look
absolutely terrible so the left needs to
make it like crystal clear that this
stuff cannot be tolerated
it cannot be toyed with it cannot be
entertained period and you know Pat it
is a small percentage of the left but
like Jonathan Hite said it has the
effect of it being a much larger
percentage of the left because of how
the right will seize on this nonsense
and crush us for it we can't have this
stuff we just can't have it policy
positions have to be number one after
that you can look at things like
character and values and identity comes
far after that and I think this logic is
just silly at the end of the day and it
gets really wishy-washy to like does she
discount Bernie Sanders he is a white
man but he's also Jewish so that's a
minority at some periods of time in
history Jews were not considered white
so I'm not sure if he's allowed to be
supported by her or someone like beta
Roark who is Irish American but hey he
has a Hispanic nickname and he speaks
Spanish so is that acceptable I think
this is just a really silly conversation
to have it's completely silly it's
completely counterproductive and that's
exactly the problem as soon as you start
saying this is how you will evaluate
candidates you get into stuff like okay
well Jews are an extreme minority but
they're often characterized as having
the same white privilege because they
pass as white but at the same time
anti-semitism is rampant so what do you
do with Bernie right immediately this is
why you got to get away from this stuff
it should be condemned if I'm missing
something let me know I really want to
hear from you if you think I'm missing
something
today's program is sponsored in part by
Blink asam / Pakman if you've not
already heard about blink Asst it's
amazing it's an app for your phone
tablet or web browser and what they do
is they take nonfiction books popular
nonfiction critically acclaimed
nonfiction they condense the book into a
fifteen minute audio book you get all
the most important information and
insights from each book but you can soak
up the entire essence of the book in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blankest one recent one is a Robert
Rice's new book the common good also
bunk by Kevin Young useful in preparing
me for the pseudo-science miniseries
that we're producing and if you are a
david pakman show viewer or listener you
can get a seven day free trial by going
to blink accom slash Pakman if you're
watching on youtube use the link in the
video description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/pa ke ma n